romo abramovich is dead what okay he's
not dead he didn't die no he's he's the
owner of chelsea russian oligarch and is
suspected to have
suffered poisoning
interesting who do you think is trying
to take him out
arsenal head coach of arsenal
no for real what is the is it you think
it's the kremlin so like no one knows so
the allegedly's are the hardliners that
want to sabotage the talks oh so these
are people we don't know but
it's obviously being permitted that
talks can happen and he's a part of it
between they're in belarus and russia
he's part of the negotiation between
russia and ukraine and two ukrainian
peace negotiators were said to have also
been affected
so maybe russia poisoned them at the
negotiations
yeah in order to not continue
negotiating fam poisoning is old-school
crazy what are you [ __ ] up russia
against that that's how much love
that's why they're not a threat actually
i've realized because they're too in the
stone age with this [ __ ] you think like
still doing this kind of warfare is mad
ancient antiquated we're still poisoning
people what is this grow up and like
what happened though like you just got
sick for a little bit yeah i didn't even
kill him [ __ ]
yeah like what what is that food
poisoning he said it's curious
guys oh wow yeah huh piercing pain in
the eyes and then
and then they uh recovered izzy that
mean come on so shortly after
allegations emerged an unnamed u.s
officials quoted by reuters as saying it
is again from reuters that the
intelligence suggests that the men's
symptoms were due to environmental
factors not poisoning at all of course
of course
so
what do we think i don't know but that's
wild man poison yeah poison's a wild one
well that's what happened to old boy
what's his name he's the u.s
he was like the u.s pick for ukrainian
president i forget his name zielinski
no this is common all dissenters against
the government
yeah victor yukashenko yeah you remember
when we thought we would care
you said something at the oscars yeah we
forgot about that will smith russia
might have had him do that oh that way
zalinski don't have to talk and nobody
cares [ __ ] yeah so this so basically
like this was during an election like
early 2000s you had uh yushenko who was
a like kind of like american-backed his
wife was like a us like worked in the
white house
like tight with all them and then you
had like a russian pick
that was another ukrainian guy that like
was tight with russia and the two of
them were fighting for it and the
american dude got poisoned
and then he has like a skin condition
ever since
oh my god wow
they don't they still says they're like
we don't even know what does that
that's [ __ ] cool oh my god yeah
he has grayscale yeah that's it they
gave him greyscale bro holy [ __ ] yeah
dude yeah russia is some real live game
of thrones [ __ ] yeah yeah they got
dragons probably
i would believe that wouldn't surprise
me i would believe that putin is
daenerys
100 yeah yeah that other guy alex
navalny oh yeah he's just locked up in
prison yeah oh no he died
no i think he did right no no i think he
just got locked up navalny i think he's
still out here he recovered and then he
got locked up yeah yeah but he's the one
that flew back and they were like yeah
put me in jail i'm about it
right
but yeah bro the poison is just crazy
yeah i don't know man that's why you got
to cheers every time
you got to cheers that's what cheersing
is yeah what do you doing you look
someone in the eye you go yo cheers and
then you drink at the same time to make
sure you don't poison it
because they're drinking too yeah but
they could just poison your drink you'd
be fine why would that change anything
no you switched drinks and you also make
sure it's poured out of the same thing
yeah i think i think back in the day it
was just poured from a bottle of wine or
poured from a beer i thought it was to
clink the cups and get the water to
participate in each one you just made
that no i didn't wait no way
cheers
what's the easiest way
was drinking was drink toasting
originally a way to avoid poison
clinking glass yeah star's way to g
guard against poisoning
uh
the clinking two glass together would
cause a liquid from both to spill into
one another miss stop no that's not true
from what i believe it you think he's on
something
it's the edu site
hospitality
edu educating educating both dummies
[ __ ] mark i thought we were onto that
there's no way that's what it is yeah i
don't think this is like a researcher
being like yeah we suspect that the
original
yeah
right
cheers
look at each other he was nice
to look into each other's eyes i love a
better point
oh it's honorable i looked into your
eyes no because you push it and then you
drink from the same [ __ ] why is it
looking yourself way worse
than with the eyes make sure when you're
doing it you're not slipping some [ __ ]
in their drink oh oh yeah cheers cheers
and then someone goes whoop yeah yeah
yeah yeah y'all never been poisoned you
don't know nothing about poison
[ __ ] idiot you're wrong
yeah you had nothing you stupid damn bro
damn according to this it says it was a
a syrup a ceremonial traditional thing
so we're both wrong
oh
don't drag me down
be wrong
[Laughter]
thank you for saying you were wrong
you